>> ARLETTE SAENZ, CERTAINLY
EXPLAINS THE CAUTION WE HAVE
HEARD IN THOSE RECENT HOURS
INCLUDING LAST NIGHT.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS RETIRED
ARMY BRIG ADRIAN GENERAL MARK
KIMMICK.
STILL AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION
BUT IT APPEARS THE MOST LIKELY
SCENARIO IS THIS WAS EITHER A
UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSE MISSILE OR
PERHAPS A COMBINATION OF THAT
AND A RUSSIAN MISSILE STRIKE.
BUT THAT KIND OF STRIKE IN THE
MIDST OF A MASSIVE RUSSIAN
BARRAGE ON UKRAINIAN TERRITORY
WHICH WAS TAKING PLACE DURING
THIS TIME FRAME, WHO BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> WELL, LOOK, I MEAN,
ULTIMATELY RUSSIA BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT SHOT THE
CRUISE MISSILES, CANDIDLY, THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT STARTED THIS
UNPROVOKED WAR.
WHILE THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
TACTICAL MISTAKES MADE ON THE
GROUND, THE RESPONSIBILITY IS
CLEARLY WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN AND
NO ONE ELSE.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, AS
WE JUST HEARD FROM MATTHEW, THE
POLISH PRIME MINISTER NOTING
THAT THERE IS AN INDICATION THAT
LIKELY IT WAS THIS UKRAINIAN
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM THAT
INTERCEPTED A RUSSIAN MISSILE
BUT THAT FRAGMENTS OF BOTH --
THEY APPEAR TO HAVE FOUND
FRAGMENTS OF BOTH ON THE GROUND
THERE IN POLAND.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
JUST HOW CLOSE RUSSIA IS
POTENTIAL GETTING WITH THESE
STRIKES TO THE POLISH BORDER?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT CAN VERY
WELL BE THAT THEY INTENTIONALLY
PROGRAMMED THOSE CRUISE MISSILES
TO FLY NEAR THE BORDER,
BELIEVING THAT THE UKRAINIANS
WOULD HOLD THEIR FIRE FOR FEAR
OF THIS VERY INCIDENT, BUT IT
WAS RESPONSIBLE ON THE PART OF
THE UKRAINIANS TO DEFEND THEIR
PEOPLE SO IF THE RUSSIANS IN MY
MIND PROBABLY TRIED TO GET THIS
AS CLOSE TO THE BORDER AS
POSSIBLE TO CAUSE THE UKRAINIANS
NOT TO SHOOT AT IT, I MEAN,
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER OF A SERIES
OF WAR CRIMES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED BY PRESIDENT PUTIN.
>> YOU SAW A LOT -- WE HEARD A
LOT OF CAUTION FROM U.S. AND
NATO OFFICIALS LAST NIGHT SAYING
LET'S NOT, YOU KNOW, JUMP TO A
CONCLUSION HERE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE'RE WATCHING THIS VERY
CLOSELY.
THAT CAUTION SEEMED TO BE
WARRANTED.
DID UKRAINIAN LEADERS MAKE A
MISTAKE BY IMMEDIATELY CALLING
THIS, CHARACTERIZING THIS AS A
RUSSIAN STRIKE ON POLAND?
>> WELL, AGAIN, I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE UKRAINIANS WERE
NECESSARILY PART OF THAT
DELIBERATIVE METHODICAL PROCESS
AT THE NATO HEADQUARTERS, BUT
THESE KIND OF ACCIDENTS, I MEAN,
WE'VE OFTEN SAID THE FIRST
REPORT IS USUALLY WRONG WHEN IT
COMES TO WARFARE.
SO I THINK WHAT NATO DID TO KIND
OF TAKE A DEEP BREATH, TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
>> WE ALSO HEARD FROM NATO
SECRETARY GENERAL THIS MORNING
WHO SAID ONE OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES NOW IS TO PROVIDE
MORE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS FOR
UKRAINE.
DO YOU THINK THIS INCIDENT WILL
SPEED UP THAT SUPPORT AND OR THE
TIMELINE FOR MORE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS OR ANY WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT'S BEING SUPPLIED TO
UKRAINE?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE SO NOT ONLY
MORE, BUT ALSO MORE ACCURATE,
MORE ADVANCED WEAPON SYSTEMS
THAN WE'VE SEEN SO FAR.
THIS COULD VERY WELL HAVE BEEN
THE SAME TYPE OF MISSILE THAT
BROUGHT DOWN THE SINGAPORE
AIRLINES FOUR YEARS AGO IN 2017.
NOT VERY ACCURATE, DEPENDS ON A
SECOND-GENERATION TYPE OF
GUIDANCE SYSTEM.
SO MORE ACCURATE, MORE OF THEM
WOULD MAKE THI